[موسيقى]
في عام
ورغم انه لم يملك سوى عشره ماركات فقط اي
ما يعادل 50 دولارا تمكن من انشاء دار
للنشر لاصدار منشورات عن مخاطر النازيه
وما يصله من معلومات ضدها قبل اشهر قليله
من اعلان الحرب في سبتمبر عام
1939 وافق روسلر الذي اتصل به العقيد هاوس
مان ماسون رئيس المخابرات السويسريه على
وقف نشر هذه المعلومات في منشوراته
لايصالها مباشره الى الاجهزه السويسريه
في احدى المرات زار رودولف ضابطين
المانيين وهما
اللذان تورطا بمؤامره لقتل هتلر وزوداه
بمعلومات عن الغزو الوشيكي لبولندا فقدمها
للمخابرات السويسريه لكنهم اهملوها لكنه
قبل كعميل لديهم بعد التاكد من معلومات
قدمها حول عمليه بربروسا رغم ذلك بقيت
اخباره غير مهمه للسويسريين بذات الدرجه
عند السوفييت الذين نشطت لديهم انذاك شبكه
التجسسيه في سويسرا تحت قياده الكسندر
ريدولفي الذي قبل رودولف للعمل ضمنها في
عام 1940 ادار روسلار نحو 80 عميلا كما
استاجر مترجم لاعمال النشر الخاصه به وهو
كريستيان شنايدر فارسل عن طريق وعن طريق
عميل بولندي هو رشيد ديبند معلومات موثوقه
من جميع اقسام الجيش الالماني كتفاصيل
تحركات القوات وجداول الغزو وقوه المعدات
والاسلحه حتى اعداد الضحايا وفي كثير من
الاحيان تم نقل الاوامر العسكريه
الالمانيه الى الروس قبل ان تتلقاها
الوحدات نفسها
عرفت حلقه التجسس التي ادارها رودولف باسم
حلقه لوسي وقدرت المعلومات التي قدمتها
على مدار خمس سنوات الى روسيا بانها قد
تملا نحو اربعين كتابا متوسطا قبل ان تقبض
عليه الشرطه السويسريه في التاسع من مايو
عام
1944 حيث سجن اربعه شهور بعد الحرب عمل
رودولف روسلار الصحفيا مستقلا لكنه وبسبب
صعوبات الماليه قام بالتجسس لصالح الحكومه
تشيكوسلوفاكيه ونقل لهم معلومات عن اسلحه
الولايات المتحده وان جلترا وفرنسا في
المانيا الغربيه فقبض عليه مره اخرى في
مارس عام
1953 وسجن لتسعه اشهر عاد بعدها الى
لوسيرن وبقي فيها حتى وفاته في الحادي عشر
من ديسمبر عام 1958